we should do the
anti-entrepreneur podcast yeah hi folks
welcome back to the entrepreneur hour um
thanks for tuning in you're probably
stupid so we've uh toned everything down
a little bit and we've made things a bit
realistic for you now Noel you have a
500 million dollar portfolio right do
you think someone else could do this I
do not okay most people they just don't
have the drive you know right and I
don't say that in a way to motivate you
I mean that like you will not you won't
ever do what I what I did so should they
give up not give up I think like
definitely strive for what's realistic
you know like maybe let's work on a 50
000 job okay um I wouldn't get your
hopes up gotcha okay this type of wealth
is um it's built uh by generation so
you're saying they're worthless not
worthless because they'll be worth
something I gotcha okay
to someone to me everyone's just a
customer